шановні українці вчора Наша команда
зазнала ще однією болючою на поправною
втрати в боях на Донеччині загинув наш
партійці Запоріжжя кіборг науковець дуже
порядна та світла людина В'ячеслав зайця
вічна пам'ять герою і усім полеглим
воїнам
В'ячеслав як і десятки тисяч інших
захисників України звільняв свою землю
від російського окупанта поки увесь
цивілізований світ засуджує псевдо
референдуми піддолами автоматів і
крадіжку окупованих територій України
збройні сили України залишаються
найкраще матидотом від путінського
безумства саме успіхи української армії
змусили Путіна йти в а-банк охолоджувати
на Росії мобілізацію від якої росіяни
тікають як чорт від ладану поспіхом
анексовувати окуповані території щоб
шантажувати увесь світ і залякувати
українцям ядерним дрючком
варто відзначити що значну роль у цьому
шабаші під вивіскою референдуму на
окупованих територіях відіграли ті хто
роками ховався у списках проросійських
партій партії які заборонені українським
судом який тягнули сюди руський мир Наша
команда розробила законопроект який
проведе масштабну люстрацію
проросійських посіпак на усіх рівнях
розрахуємо що більшість у Раді готова
підтримати цю ініціативу і якщо
українська армія головна запорука нашої
сьогоднішньої Перемоги то членство в
НАТО запорука мирного життя наших дітей
саме тому членство НАТО завжди було
стратегічною метою для команди
європейської солідарності Ми вітаємо
рішення подати заявку від України на
вступ до Альянсу і не просто вітаємо а
допомагаємо досягнути успіху своїми
діями прямо зараз Петро Порошенко на
міжнародних зустрічах в Швеції та
Великобританії закликає партнерам
підтримати заявку України більше того
Він наполягає що Альянс розглянув
процедуру прийняття За прикладом Швеції
і Фінляндії Бо Україна вже заплатила
дуже високу ціну за право перебувати в
НАТО без додаткових умов НАТО ще більше
зброї ще більше пекельних санкцій проти
Росії міцнати путинська коаліція та
економічна підтримка України ось 5
головних елементів формули Перемоги які
Порошенко презентував союзникам і ми
очікуємо що ці п'ять пунктів не будуть
порожнім звуком і для української влади
наше головне завдання Сьогодні якісний
бюджет на 2023 рік якісний - це
першочергове фінансування армії а не
витрата майже 100 мільярдів на дороги як
заплановано зараз якісний - це підтримка
найвразливіших Вест населення а не
економія на найбідніших якісний - це
розумні витрати на правоохоронну систему
а не викинуті два з половиною мільярди
на недолуги дбр яке знову клепає
ефективні справи проти політичних
опонентів влади
європейська Солідарність вже підготувала
свою пропозицію до бюджету і готова
відстоювати здоровий глузд при
формуванні кошторису воюючої країни на
наступний рік Дякую за увагу